>>> IN A FLASHBACK TO 2020 LAST
NIGHT, FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP HELD A RALLY IN A STATE
BEING RAVAGED BY COVID.
THIS TIME IT WAS A RALLY IN
ALABAMA WHICH HAS THE LOWEST
VACCINATION RATE IN THE COUNTRY
AND IS OUT OF ICU BEDS.
AT ONE POINT, TRUMP DID URGE
ATTENDEES TO GET VACCINATED BUT
THEN BACKED OFF AFTER SOME OF
THE MAGA FAITHFUL BOOED.
WATCH.
>> I RECOMMEND, TAKE THE
VACCINES.
I DID IT.
IT'S GOOD.
TAKE THE VACCINES.
BUT YOU GOT -- NO, THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
YOU GOT YOUR FREEDOMS.
BUT I HAPPEN TO TAKE THE
VACCINE.
>> NOT EXACTLY A RINGING
ENDORSEMENT.
CNN'S DOANIE O'SULLIVAN IS IN
ALABAMA WHERE HE COVERED TRUMP
YESTERDAY.
TRUMP POLITICIDZED COVID
PREVENTION MEASURES.
HE GOT THE VACCINE IN SECRET.
WE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT.
BEFORE HE LEFT OFFICE.
NOW HE'S SEEING THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THAT, IT SEEMS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S REALLY REMARKABLE TO HEAR
THE BOOS AND THE CROWD GOING
SILENT ESSENTIALLY WHEN TRUMP
MENTIONED THE VACCINE.
LOOK, TRUMP CAN TAKE A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR THIS VACCINE AND WE
KNOW TRUMP LIKES TO TAKE CREDIT
WHERE HE CAN AND SOMETIMES WHERE
HE CAN'T.
BUT HE KNOWS IN THIS SITUATION
SO MUCH OF HIS BASE ARE SO, SO
AGAINST THIS VACCINE AND THAT IS
I THINK, REALLY SORT OF -- IT'S
AN EXAMPLE OF THE BASE
CONTROLLING TRUMP RATHER THAN
THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
ONE THING THAT WE HEARD FROM
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN THE PAST FEW MONTHS
IS THEY DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE
VACCINE UNTIL IT GETS FULL
GOVERNMENT APPROVAL.
THE PFIZER SHOT REPORTEDLY IS
EXPECTED TO GET THAT FULL FDA
APPROVAL THIS WEEK AND WE ASKED
SOME PEOPLE ABOUT THAT.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> HAVE YOU GOT YOUR VACCINE
SHOT?
>> NOPE, DON'T WANT IT.
>> WHY NOT?
>> THEY AIN'T TESTED IT ENOUGH,
FROM MY OPINION.
>> SO THE PFIZER SHOT, IT'S
ABOUT TO GET FULL FDA APPROVAL.
WOULD THAT CHANGE YOUR OPINION
ON IT?
>> NOT UNTIL MORE INVESTIGATING
IN ON IT.
NOTHING IS GOING IN ME UNTIL
THEN.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD TAKE
A LONG TIME?
>> ABOUT TEN YEARS OR SO.
>> THERE'S A BIG SURGE IN COVID
CASES HERE IN YOUR COUNTY AT THE
MOMENT.
HAVE YOU GUYS BEEN VACCINATED?
>> YES.
>> YOU BOTH DECIDED TO GET THE
VACCINE?
>> YES.
>> SOME TRUMP SUPPORTERS HAVE
AND SOME TRUMP SUPPORTERS
HAVEN'T.
WHY DID YOU GUYS ULTIMATELY
DECIDE TO GET THE SHOT?
>> JUST FELT IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
>> PROTECTION.
>> YEAH.
>> ADDED PROTECTION.
DO ANYTHING WE CAN TO BE
PROTECTED.
>> YES.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FRIENDS OR
NEIGHBORS WHO DECIDED NOT TO
TAKE THE SHOT?
HAVE YOU TRIED TO ENCOURAGE ANY
FOLKS YOU KNOW TO GET THE SHOT?
>> OH, YEAH.
TRY TO ENCOURAGE AS MUCH AS WE
CAN BUT YOU CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH.
>> THAT COUPLE THERE, JIM, IN A
VERY SMALL MINORITY OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WE MET WHO HAVE GOT
THE SHOT.
WE SPOKE TO A LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIAL HERE THIS MORNING WHO
IS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT LAST
NIGHT'S EVENT.
THERE WAS A VERY BIG CROWD THERE
AND WITH COVID CASES BEING SO
HIGH IN THE STATE AT THE MOMENT
AND A HIGH CONCENTRATION OF
VACCINATED PEOPLE, SHE EXPECTS
TO SEE CASES COME OUT -- COME AS
A RESULT OF THAT RALLY LAST
NIGHT.
>> AND DONIE, TRUMP ALSO
CONTINUED HIS TRADITION OF
PRAISING QUESTIONABLE PEOPLE.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
YEAH, TRUMP HAD A LOT TO SAY
ABOUT AFGHANISTAN AND THE
TALIBAN LAST NIGHT, BLAMING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND CALLING
OUT WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS THE
WOKE GENERALS FOR THEIR
MISMANAGEMENT OF AFGHANISTAN.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> THIS ISN'T STOPPING.
THIS IS GOING TO GO ON FOR A
LONG TIME.
THIS ISN'T GOING AWAY.
THIS ISN'T LIKE A THREE-DAY HIT.
IT'S GOING TO GO ON FOR A LONG
TIME.
TALIBAN, GREAT NEGOTIATORS.
TOUGH FIGHTERS, GREAT
NEGOTIATORS.
45,000 PEOPLE?
YOU GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE ALSO
THAT DESERVE TO BE HELPED AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LET THEM BE
HELPED AT ALL.
THIS IS GOING TO GO ON FOR A
LONG TIME.
IT'S A GREAT STAIN ON THE
REPUTATION OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> TOUGH FIGHTERS AND GREAT
NEGOTIATORS ARE THE TALIBAN,
SAYS TRUMP.
AS YOU HEARD THERE, HE MENTIONED
THIS IS GOING TO GO ON FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
HE VERY MUCH WANTS TO MAKE THIS
AN ISSUE FOR NEXT YEAR'S
MIDTERMS AND GOING INTO 2024 AS
WELL.
>> OF COURSE, DONIE, TRUMP IS
LEAVING OUT THE FACT IT WAS HIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT CUT THIS
DEAL WITH THE TALIBAN THAT HE
ALMOST INVITED THE TALIBAN.
HE DID INVITE THE TALIBAN TO
CAMP DAVID BUT PULLED BACK THAT
INVITATION AND THEN HIS OWN
SECRETARY OF STATE CUT A DEAL
WITH THE TALIBAN LATER DESCRIBED
AS A SURRENDER AGREEMENT BY THE
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER, H.R. McMASTER.
SO TRUMP RIGHT THERE PLAYING
REVISIONIST HISTORY AND TRYING
TO WASH HIS HANDS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
OF COURSE,